Some bread, a warm meal, - or even socks:
Migrants are getting help from individuals
and institutions, like in this hostel in Mexico
City.
Viviana Gutierrez is one of those who turned
out.
Today she drove a van over loaded with clothes
for women and children.
It's gratifying that a lot of people are helping.
It brings out the humanity in us and it pleases
me to see the difference we are making.
We're all very proud to be Mexican.
Mexico has seen migrants bound northwards
travel through the country for decades.
This is a chance for it to express solidarity
with foreigners.
We have to deal with this acutely painful
situation, to reach out to people passing
through who are in need."
Colombians and Hondurans think that we reject
them, but we have to support each other because
we are all human beings, and we feel for them."
But these people haven't been welcomed by
everyone...
Some Mexicans have begun lashing out at the
migrants.
"They have no problems because they don't
work.
If they come here to contribute, they're welcome.
It seems like they're having a day at the
beach - they don't wear shirts, they throw
away the food we give them, but they keep
the beer."
Many of them are drunk, urinating in public
everywhere.
Mexico cannot cope with receiving them.
I hope that from now on officials check their
papers and give them what they deserve, and
give us what we deserve.
Their human rights are apparently worth more
than ours.
Some of the migrants have felt that lack of
sensitivity during their journey.
But even so, most say Mexico has offered them
good care.
Just now one person insulted us.
We didn't like that but I guess we have to
accept it.
We are invading their country"
"Mexico has received us very well.
We are very proud because it has given us
all this support, we have not lacked food,
clothing."
Mexico - a country divided, like so many others,
by migration.